In Houston it's Tuesday at the Astrodome complex. We still had thousands of evacuees from New Orleans at that point. There were these tables with hand-lettered signs on poster board-- they read Florida, New York, Colorado-- basically offering to relocate evacuees to those states. This wasn't the state governments doing this. This was private charities and churches from those states, and they're making some incredibly generous offers.
在休斯顿的阿斯托巨蛋综合大楼（Astrodome complex），现在是周二。当时我们仍有数千名来自新奥尔良的灾民。那里摆放着几张桌子，上面有海报板手写的牌子——写着佛罗里达州、纽约州、科罗拉多州——基本上是提出将灾民重新安置到这些州。这不是州政府的行为，而是来自这些州的私人慈善机构和教会，他们提出了非常慷慨的条件。
I think that people should come to Colorado because we've got the best deal going.
我认为人们应该来科罗拉多州，因为我们提供的条件最好。
Andrea [? Ames ?] was manning the Colorado table on behalf of three different charities there. And the deal she's offering?
安德里亚·埃姆斯（Andrea Ames）代表当地的三家不同慈善机构负责科罗拉多州的接待台。而她提供的条件是什么呢？
It's free housing that's been donated by citizens of Colorado for anywhere from six months to a year. They've also promised to furnish the houses, fill them with groceries for that six-month time, job training, and a job.
这是科罗拉多州市民捐赠的免费住房，居住时间从六个月到一年不等。他们还承诺提供家具，在六个月内供应食品杂货，并提供就业培训和一份工作。
But incredibly, even though this deal did seem to be the very best deal going at the Astrodome complex, people from New Orleans don't want this deal.
但令人难以置信的是，尽管这个条件看起来是阿斯托巨蛋综合大楼里最好的选择，但新奥尔良来的人并不想要这个条件。
For the first two weeks our team was here, there was no one going at all. There was no one signing up. It took me three days-- I had one specific offer-- it took me three days to give away one free three-bedroom, two-bathroom house, free car, free insurance for a year, free schooling for the kids, one job at Coca Cola, one job with Wal-Mart. It took me three days to get someone to take it.
我们团队刚来这里的前两周，根本没有人愿意去。没有人报名。我花了好几天时间——我有一个具体的提议——花了三天时间才送出一套免费的三居室两卫房子，外加免费车、一年免费保险、孩子免费上学、可口可乐的一份工作，以及沃尔玛的一份工作。我花了三天时间才说服有人接受它。
And why?
为什么？
Everybody said, if I come to Colorado, I'm going to freeze to death. Everyone thinks they're going to die. Everyone thinks we all live in Alaska and it snows every day all year around and that we're all going to freeze to death. They really say, I can't go there, I'm going to die. We aren't like you. We don't live like that. That's been the biggest conversation I've had probably the most.
每个人都说，如果我去科罗拉多州，我会冻死的。大家都以为自己会死。大家都以为我们住的地方和阿拉斯加一样，一年四季每天都在下雪，我们都会冻死。他们真的说，我不能去那里，我会死的。我们不像你们，我们的生活方式不一样。这大概是我听过最多的话了。
Which is all hard enough for Andrea to deal with on its face, but then there's the added indignity that her candidates then go two tables down and get snapped up by Florida.
这让安德里亚面对起来已经够难了，但更令人沮丧的是，她好不容易选中的人转头走到两个摊位开外，就被佛罗里达州的人抢走了。
Actually, we had a young lady-- as a matter of fact, the family just left today-- that we just flew out of here today.
其实，我们确实有一位年轻女士——事实上，那家人今天刚走——我们今天刚把他们送上飞机。
Kevin [? Lillibride ?] at the Florida table.
这是佛罗里达州接待台的凯文·里利布赖德（Kevin Lillibride）。
And they were considering Colorado, and that was the issue. It was the difference between snow and sun, and we just looked at them and said, really, what's holding you up? We have sun, and they have snow. So it helps us out when they go talk to Colorado, because then they come down here to talk to us. It works in our favor.
他们当时在考虑科罗拉多，这就是症结所在。这只是下雪和阳光的区别，我们看着他们说，到底是什么在阻碍你们？我们这里有阳光，他们那里有雪。所以当他们去和科罗拉多谈的时候，反而帮了我们的忙，因为之后他们就会来找我们。这对我们有利。
The only problem with Florida, of course, is something that everybody from New Orleans pretty much has a low tolerance for at this point: hurricanes. Still, as of Tuesday, the guys at the Florida table got 43 families to relocate.
当然，佛罗里达州唯一的问题是新奥尔良人目前最无法忍受的东西：飓风。不过，截至周二，佛罗里达州接待台的工作人员已经成功安置了43个家庭。
You're listening to This American Life from WBEZ Chicago, distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass.
您正在收听的是由WBEZ芝加哥制作、国际公共广播电台（PRI）发行的《美国生活》（This American Life）。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。
So this past week, somewhere between 400,000 and a million people, including an entire city, New Orleans, were scattered across the country, the biggest mass resettlement in our country since the Civil War. And we went out to document some of what was happening as these people tried to figure out what happens next in their lives, where they're going to live.
过去这一周，大约有40万到100万人，包括整个新奥尔良市的人口，散布到了全国各地。这是自南北战争以来我国最大规模的群体性安置行动。我们出发去记录这些正在发生的事情，记录这些人如何试图决定生活的下一步，以及他们将住在哪里。
Two producers from our radio show, Lisa Pollak and Jane  Feltes, and I flew from our home base in Chicago to Houston. Houston is where between 150,000 and 200,000 hurricane evacuees went after the hurricane. One man I talked to down there who was looking for housing said that he felt like he was living in a gold rush town, so many people scrambling for all the same things all at the same time. Today, we bring you stories from the Astrodome, and of people simply trying to find places to live.
我们广播节目的两位制片人丽莎·波拉克（Lisa Pollak）和简·费尔特斯（Jane Feltes），以及我，从我们在芝加哥的大本营飞往了休斯顿。休斯顿是飓风后15万至20万名飓风灾民的去处。我在那里遇到的一位寻找住房的人说，他感觉自己住在一个淘金热时期的城镇，这么多人同时在为同样的东西争抢。今天，我们将为您带来阿斯托巨蛋里那些努力寻找住处的人们的故事。
Plus, back in New Orleans, certain business owners in certain areas are being allowed back this weekend. Nick Spitzer drives through deserted streets to his own house, where he feels like a stranger and a looter. Stay with us.
此外，回到新奥尔良，某些地区的特定企业主这个周末被允许返回。尼克·斯皮策（Nick Spitzer）开车穿过荒凉的街道回到自己的家，在那里他感到自己像个陌生人和抢劫者。请继续收听。
It was actually Jane who talked to people at the various state tables, and she says eventually Colorado did actually manage to get some people to relocate.
其实是简负责与各州接待台的人交谈，她说最终科罗拉多州确实成功安置了一些人。
They got 35 people after two weeks of trying. And the reason people finally said yes was desperation. FEMA let everyone know that the temporary housing was ending, hotel vouchers were ending for families that were in hotels, and people were being moved out of the Astrodome. First in line for the bus to Colorado were twin sisters, [? Coquin ?] and [? Kayla. ?] They're six. And here's what they know about the place they're about to move.
在尝试了两周后，他们安置了35人。人们最终答应的原因是绝望。联邦紧急事务管理局（FEMA）通知所有人临时住所即将到期，住旅馆的家庭的凭证也将到期，人们将被撤出阿斯托巨蛋。排在前往科罗拉多州巴士队伍最前面的是双胞胎姐妹科奎恩（Coquin）和凯拉（Kayla）。她们才六岁。以下是她们对自己即将搬去的地方的了解。
I know that it's beautiful. It's a beautiful place, and it has lots of mountains. And I know that it's so beautiful, anybody will want to go there.
我知道那里很美。那是一个美丽的地方，有很多山。而且我知道它非常美丽，任何人都会想去那里。
Where did you hear that?
你从哪里听说的？
I heard it from a snow movie, like Snow Dogs. You know Snow Dogs? It took place in-- what's the name of the place again?
我是从一部关于雪的电影里听说的，比如《雪地黄金犬》（Snow Dogs）。你知道《雪地黄金犬》吗？它发生在——那个地方叫什么名字来着？
Colorado.
科罗拉多州。
In Colorado.
在科罗拉多州。
Colorado.
科罗拉多州。
How's the last couple of weeks been?
过去这两周过得怎么样？
It's like [INTERPOSING VOICES] adventure. Let me say it. It's like an adventure. We been almost everywhere. We had so much fun. We went to Baton Rouge, went to the shelter, and then Alexandria, then back to Baton Rouge, then to Houston. We had to live in a hotel, the Scottish. Yeah, the Scottish Hotel and Suites. That's what it said.
就像一场冒险。让我说，这就像一场冒险。我们几乎去了所有地方。我们玩得很开心。我们去了巴吞鲁日，去了避难所，然后是亚历山大，然后又回到了巴吞鲁日，最后到了休斯顿。我们不得不住在一家酒店，苏格兰酒店（The Scottish）。对，就是苏格兰酒店及套房。牌子上是这么写的。
When I talked to their mom, [? Coquina, ?] she said that they overheard her talking on the phone telling a friend that the last few weeks have really been an adventure. She was being sarcastic, but the girls picked it up. And just as well. It took a little more convincing for their mom.
当我与她们的妈妈科奎娜（Coquina）交谈时，她说女儿们无意中听到她在电话里告诉朋友，过去这几周真是一场冒险。她当时是在讽刺，但女孩们当真了。这样也好。说服她们的母亲则多花了一些功夫。
I saw that New York, the cost of living is too high to start there. And I thought, I don't want to go to Florida by any more storms, so Colorado seems safe.
我看到纽约的生活成本太高，不适合从头开始。我心想，我不想再去佛罗里达面对更多的暴风雨了，所以科罗拉多看起来很安全。
And why not Houston?
那为什么不去休斯顿呢？
Well, I was trying to establish in Houston, but like I said, I only had 14 days to get everything done. Otherwise, we'd be on the street trying to get it done. So when I heard Colorado, I jumped on there.
好吧，我本来想在休斯顿安顿下来，但就像我说的，我只有14天的时间完成所有事情。否则我们就会流落街头。所以当我听到科罗拉多的消息时，我就抓住了机会。
Oh Jane, you ought to be ashamed, you let a boy kiss you and you don't know his name.
噢简，你应该感到羞愧，你让一个男孩亲了你，却连他名字都不知道。
At this point, the girls decided I was done talking to their mom, and they wanted the microphone back, which they suddenly realized was real, and I actually was from the radio, and they had business.
此时，女孩们决定我没必要再跟她们妈妈谈话了，她们想要回麦克风。她们突然意识到这是真的，而我也确实是电台的人，她们还有正事要说。
About the hurricane and our sister and brother, we can't find them.
关于飓风，还有我们的姐姐和弟弟，我们找不到他们了。
You can't find your brother and sister?
你们找不到哥哥和姐姐了？
No. When Katrina hit, we never heard from since we left. If [? Kiana ?] and Jamal is listening to this, we love you and we miss you.
是的。卡特里娜飓风袭来后，我们离开后就再也没有他们的消息。如果基亚娜（Kiana）和贾马尔（Jamal）正在听这段节目，我们爱你们，我们想念你们。
We met lots of people at the Astrodome who were still missing friends and family. There's an office that reunites families, with lists of survivors and their locations, but their moms says the last time they saw Jamal and [? Kiana ?] was when she dropped them off with their dad and grandparents in New Orleans before evacuating, just before the storm. She's acting confident that they're OK, so the girls are acting confident too.
我们在阿斯托巨蛋遇到了许多仍在寻找失踪亲友的人。那里有个办公室负责团聚家庭，有幸存者名单和他们的下落。但她们的妈妈说，最后一次见到贾马尔和基亚娜是飓风前疏散时，她把他们交给了在新奥尔良的父亲和祖父母照顾。她表现得很确定他们平安无事，所以女孩们也就表现得很确定。
Act Two, There's No Place Like Dome. So what was it like this week in those huge buildings that were housing evacuees in Houston? Well, the first thing you noticed when you walked into the Astrodome or the Reliant Convention Center, where people were living, was the noise.
第二幕，巨蛋里就像家一样。那么，本周在休斯顿收容灾民的那些巨大建筑里是什么感觉？好吧，当你走进阿斯托巨蛋或灾民居住的莱里安特会议中心（Reliant Convention Center）时，你注意到的第一件事就是噪音。
James Scott, James Scott, pick up at the front gate. Tyrone Scott is waiting for you.
詹姆斯·斯科特（James Scott），詹姆斯·斯科特，请到正门来接人。泰隆·斯科特（Tyrone Scott）正在等你。
PA announcements went on all day and into the night. In the center of the Astrodome, the area there where the cots were, because you were right under the center of the dome itself, it echoed like crazy.
广播公告从早到晚响个不停。在阿斯托巨蛋的中心，就是那些折叠床所在的区域，因为你就在巨蛋中心的正下方，回音大得惊人。
Please call Auntie Harry. Her number is 7067. Thank you.
请致电哈里阿姨。她的号码是7067。谢谢。
Louis [? Llewellyn ?] told me that you get used to it. He's a New Orleans evacuee.
路易斯·卢埃林（Louis Llewellyn）告诉我，你会习惯的。他是一名新奥尔良的灾民。
Yeah, I take naps through the announcements. Yeah, you have to take naps. I'm not as young as I used to be. Yeah, the announcements won't stop me from taking a nap.
是的，我会在广播声中打盹。是的，你必须得午睡。我年纪大了，不像以前了。广播声挡不住我午睡的。
One thing about living in a big room with thousands of people that you don't really think about until you're there is germs. There are little free bottles of antibacterial scrub all over the place that people were advised to use, but that didn't stop bugs from spreading.
住在一个有数千人的大房间里，有些事情在你亲身经历之前是不会想到的，比如细菌。到处都有免费的抗菌洗手液小瓶，人们被建议使用，但这并没有阻止病毒的传播。
I caught the virus that was going around. I had diarrhea, and I was vomiting, trying to get to a dumpster, and I couldn't. I couldn't make it. And I just vomited right in the  middle of the floor.
我感染了当时流行的一种病毒。我腹泻、呕吐，想去垃圾箱，但没能成功。我没能赶上。我直接吐在了地板中间。
Bad place to get sick.
生病的地方真糟糕。
Yeah, bad place to get sick.
是啊，生病的地方真糟糕。
Or maybe not such a bad place, since just a few feet from his cot was a 24-hour medical clinic. There was also a pediatric clinic and a pharmacy. He got better in just a day.
或者可能也没那么糟糕，因为离他的床位几英尺远就是一个24小时营业的医疗诊所。还有一个儿科诊所和一家药房。他只用了一天就好了。
The lights were on all the time, though they dim them at night. It was so calm and orderly that the soldiers you saw inside the Reliant Convention Center were mostly on duty guarding the bathrooms, mainly, one said, to be sure that men and women weren't getting together in the bathrooms for some adult privacy, or, dare I say, domo-sexual activity.
灯一直亮着，尽管晚上会调暗。这里非常平静有序，你在莱里安特会议中心里看到的士兵大多是在值班看守浴室。其中一名士兵说，这主要是为了确保男女不会在浴室里进行某种成人隐私活动，或者，我敢说，类似“巨蛋性行为”。
In the late morning, the big convention floor where everybody was living looked like an apartment complex where all the walls had been lifted away. A little girl skipped around her family's cots, a teenager walked through bouncing a basketball. There was a free phone bank, and places to sign up for college, and all the offices to get insurance and government benefits, a big computer center with lots of volunteers ready to help you get online and navigate government websites.
上午晚些时候，每个人居住的大型会议中心看起来就像一个墙壁被拆除的公寓大楼。一个小女孩在家人睡觉的折叠床周围跳来跳去，一个青少年拍着篮球走过。这里有免费的电话亭，有大学报名点，还有所有办理保险和政府福利的办公室，一个大型电脑中心，许多志愿者随时准备帮助你上网并查阅政府网站。
Most of what was so striking was the overall competence of the whole thing, the care with which it was all put together. And nobody thought that more strongly than the people who were there who had been trapped at the New Orleans Convention Center, or the Superdome in New Orleans, after the flooding.
最引人注目的是整个运作的胜任能力，以及它被组织起来时的那种细致。没有人比那些在洪水过后被困在新奥尔良会议中心或超级巨蛋（Superdome）的人感触更深了。
The Superdome was like, it was just total chaos. Rapes went on. One of the young men stole one of the soldier's gun and shot in the leg.
超级巨蛋简直就是一片混乱。发生了强奸案。其中一个年轻人偷走了一名士兵的枪并打伤了腿。
This shooting, this was something you saw?
这起枪击事件，你是亲眼所见吗？
Yes. They killed, and killings were going on. It was just like, just horrible.
是的。他们杀人，杀戮事件一直在发生。这真是太可怕了。
This is Phyllis Thompson. I talked to her just as she and her son and her daughter and her grandkids were packing up their stuff to move into their new housing. The kids had one of those big plastic trash bags full of new stuffed animals that had been donated. Phyllis and her son both told me that after what they went through at the Superdome, they don't ever want to return to New Orleans.
这是菲利斯·汤普森（Phyllis Thompson）。我见到她时，她正和她的儿子、女儿以及孙辈们收拾东西准备搬进新住所。孩子们拿着一大袋捐赠的毛绒玩具。菲利斯和她的儿子都告诉我，经历了超级巨蛋的一切后，他们再也不想回到新奥尔良了。
I'm not going back. I don't want to even see it no more. Uh-uh. I ain't going back to that.
我不回去。我甚至不想再看到它。不，我不回去。我绝不回那个鬼地方。
His mom, Phyllis, says that after the flood, the moment on the bus that they crossed the border into Texas, she felt safe for the first time. She felt peace.
她的母亲菲利斯说，洪水过后，当公共汽车越过边界进入德克萨斯州的那一刻，她第一次感到安全。她感到了一种平静。
Texas has opened their heart. The state troopers, the organizations that work here, the Red Cross, it's just everybody has just showed so much love and so much kindness. And all I can say is that I just thank God for it. Even the clean-up people are so nice and just kind, and just considerate.
德克萨斯州敞开了心扉。州警、在这里工作的组织、红十字会，每个人都表现出了太多的爱和善良。我唯一能说的就是感谢上帝。连清理人员都那么友好、善良和体贴。
Not everybody was feeling quite as positive. I ran into Tony and Tiffany Davis as they were leaving the Reliant Center. An incredibly wholesome-looking young couple, they wore the color wristbands that get evacuees into the Astrodome complex, and they dragged a leopard print wheelie suitcase that had been donated by Wal-Mart, and a beat-up olive suitcase that came from an airline.
并不是每个人都感觉那么积极。我在离开莱里安特中心时遇到了托尼和蒂芙尼·戴维斯（Tony and Tiffany Davis）。这是一对看起来非常健康、令人愉快的年轻夫妇，他们戴着让灾民进入阿斯托巨蛋综合大楼的彩色腕带。他们拖着一个沃尔玛捐赠的豹纹拉杆箱，以及一个从航空公司捡来的破烂橄榄色行李箱。
Continental I think gave it to us.
我想是大陆航空给我们的。
Just like somebody's lost luggage that never like--
就像某个失物招领，从未被——
I think it was lost at the airport. Lost, yeah.
我想是在机场丢的。丢了，是的。
So that's where it ends up?
所以最终就是这样？
Yes. It's ours now.
是的。现在它是我们的了。
They're taking the free plane tickets offered by Continental and FEMA and moving to New Jersey, where Tony's brother has a house. So far the housing people in Texas haven't been able to get to their case, so they're leaving.
他们接受了大陆航空和FEMA提供的免费机票，搬去新泽西州，那里有托尼哥哥的房子。目前德克萨斯州的住房部门还没能处理他们的案件，所以他们要走了。
So how's it been here? Like, do you come out of this experience feeling kind of impressed with what they've done here in Houston, or--?
那么在这里过得怎么样？你是带着对休斯顿所做之事的钦佩感离开这里，还是——？
I think when we first arrived, that everything was pretty organized, and I think afterwards, I think they kind of got tired of us.
我想当我们刚到的时候，一切都相当有组织，我觉得后来，他们有点厌烦我们了。
Why? Why? What was the sign of that?
为什么？为什么？有什么迹象吗？
Like, we went to the mall, and I think that they see us with the bands on, and everybody's like, oh my gosh, here they come, here they come, here they come, they're coming to steal, they're coming to do this, they do that. And it's not everybody. Everybody's not like that. And I think that it's partially the media's fault. They did portray us in a bad way. The news is showing us looting, and they're showing this, and they're showing that. And I think that it just adds to the fire, and I think that that's how everybody's judging us.
比如，我们去商场时，我觉得他们看到我们手腕上的带子，每个人都像是，“哦，天哪，他们来了，他们来了，他们来了，他们是来偷东西的，他们是来干这个的，干那个的。”其实并不是每个人都这样。并不是每个人都像那样。我认为这部分是媒体的错。他们确实以糟糕的方式描绘了我们。新闻里展示我们在抢劫，展示这个，展示那个。我认为这只会火上浇油，而这就是每个人评判我们的方式。
In a shop at the Galleria mall, she says, a store employee followed her wherever she went. And just walking through town, she says, a man stepped completely off the sidewalk to avoid her and Tony. And in fact, white Texans did raise the issue with us, with me and Jane and Lisa, of what the presence of all these people from New Orleans would do to the crime rate. And the fact that it hadn't affected the crime rate was big enough news to be a front page story in the Houston Chronicle on Tuesday.
她说，在加勒里亚商场（Galleria mall）的一家店里，店员跟着她走了每一处地方。而且只是走在镇上时，她说，一个男人为了避开她和托尼，完全从人行道上走了开来。事实上，白人德州人确实向我和简、丽莎提过，关于所有这些新奥尔良人在此会对犯罪率产生什么影响的问题。而事实上，它并没有影响犯罪率，这足以成为周二《休斯顿纪事报》头版头条的大新闻。
But at the same time, what's most striking as you go around Houston is how many people are putting themselves out for days and weeks at a time for strangers from Louisiana. At Grace Community Church, for example, the congregation not only came up with over $200,000 for relief supplies and gas cards for Katrina victims, over 1,000 of them volunteered day after day, some working 12- and 14-hour days, sending out faxes to every hotel in the area offering assistance to survivors, calling apartment complexes all over the city so they could compile every day a daily list of available apartments, specifying which ones were giving special breaks to Katrina survivors. They were serving a huge population that barely made it on to the news, and didn't make it into the Astrodome. That is, people who evacuated before the hurricane, who had some resources of their own. Lori Buxton works at the church.
但与此同时，当你走遍休斯顿，最令人震惊的是有多少人连续数天甚至数周为路易斯安那州的陌生人倾尽全力。例如，在恩典社区教会（Grace Community Church），会众不仅为卡特里娜飓风受害者筹集了超过20万美元的救济物资和汽油卡，超过1000名志愿者日复一日地提供志愿服务，有些人每天工作12到14个小时，向当地每家酒店传真求助信息，致电全城的公寓大楼，以便每天编制一份可用公寓的每日名单，并标明哪些公寓为飓风幸存者提供了特殊优惠。他们服务的是一大群几乎没上过新闻，也没能进入阿斯托巨蛋的人。也就是说，在飓风来临前就撤离的、自身尚有一些资源的人。洛里·巴克斯顿（Lori Buxton）在教会工作。
Yes, primarily the people that we experienced were people that left when the storm was approaching, came here, got their hotel rooms, expecting they'd be here for three to four days while the storm went through. Of course, that turned out to be a very different situation. A week later, 10 days, 14 days later, they started running out of money. They started running out of places to stay. I had a call the day before yesterday, and I quote, "I have to be out of here in 20 minutes, and I have nowhere to go and no way to get there."
是的，我们接触的主要是那些在风暴临近时离开的人，他们来到这里，订了酒店房间，以为风暴过去后他们会在这里待三到四天。当然，情况大不相同。一周后、10天、14天后，他们的钱开始花光了。他们开始住的地方也没有了。前天我接到一个电话，原话是：“我20分钟内必须离开这里，我无处可去，也没有办法过去。”
Exactly where all these evacuees are going to live is the next serious question that this exodus is going to face. And though the Astrodome officially emptied out at the end of this week, several thousand people are still in the Reliant Arena just next door, with no particular end in sight. And beyond that group, it doesn't seem like anybody knows how many tens of thousands of people are staying in Houston paying for their own hotels, or on two-week government hotel vouchers that are now running out, or with family or friends, who are going to need permanent housing, and may need government help to help pay for it.
所有这些灾民到底要住在哪里，是这场大迁徙面临的下一个重大问题。虽然阿斯托巨蛋在本周末正式清空，但隔壁的莱里安特竞技场（Reliant Arena）仍有数千人，且看不到任何安置终点。除了那一群人之外，似乎没人知道还有多少万人在休斯顿自费住酒店，或者拿着即将到期的为期两周的政府酒店凭证，或者与家人朋友住在一起。他们都需要永久住房，可能还需要政府帮助支付费用。
There's a voucher program that the city of Houston has set up that gives you six months free rent, no security deposit, two months utilities, furniture for your apartment, stuff like a shower curtain, in pre-selected apartments that have been inspected to be sure they're OK. Which of course sounds great, but matching the apartments with all the people who need them is complicated. And that is actually the subject of Act Three of our show.
休斯顿市设立了一个凭证计划，提供六个月免费租金、免押金、两个月水电费、家具，以及浴帘等生活用品，租住的是经过检查确认合格的预选公寓。这听起来当然不错，但将公寓与所有需要它们的人匹配起来很复杂。这其实也是我们节目第三幕的主题。
Act Three, Land Grab. Lisa Pollak, one of our program's producers, went to the housing center at the Reliant Arena this week.
第三幕，土地争夺战。我们节目的制片人之一丽莎·波拉克，本周去了莱里安特竞技场的住房中心。
It's 3:00  PM when we get to the housing center, and it's not a happy place. There are hundreds of people here, slumped in folding chairs, jostling in lines, pleading for volunteers to help them. Tense-looking cops are everywhere, and soldiers in camouflage fatigues. It makes the DMV look like a day spa. In the section of chairs where we're standing, there's this sudden wave of movement. People stand up, and there's some yelling. It turns out an official with a bullhorn just told a whole group to leave and come back tomorrow. They won't get apartments today. And one of the women standing near us has clearly reached her limit.
我们下午3点到达住房中心时，那不是个令人愉快的地方。这里有数百人瘫坐在折叠椅上，在队伍中推搡，乞求志愿者帮助他们。紧张的警察到处都是，还有身穿迷彩服的士兵。这让车管所看起来就像个日间水疗中心。在我们站立的椅子区域，突然涌起了一阵波动。人们站了起来，还有些叫喊声。原来是一个拿着扩音器的工作人员刚刚告诉一大群人离开明天再来。他们今天住不上公寓了。站在我们附近的一位妇女显然已经到了极限。
You should have apartments first before you bring the people in. You're bringing the people in before the apartments is available. Now we stand in line.
你们应该在带人来之前先准备好公寓。你们在公寓可用之前就把人带过来了。现在我们得排队。
Her name is [? Ida Mae. ?] She's been here since early this morning, she says, just like she was told to be, looking for a place for herself and her teenage sons. And at this point, the only way to manage her frustration is to share it with everyone she sees, including, apparently, one of the less-tolerant cops in the room.
她的名字叫艾达·梅（Ida Mae）。她说她从今天一早就在这了，就像被要求的那样，为她自己和她十几岁的儿子寻找住所。而此时，管理她沮丧情绪的唯一方式就是与她看到的每个人分享，显然包括房间里那些不太宽容的警察之一。
The police just told me that they will arrest me and put me out. Put me out where? Where they going to put me out at? That's a threat.
警察刚刚告诉我，如果我大声喧哗，他们会逮捕我并把我赶出去。把我赶出去到哪？他们要把我赶到哪去？这是一种威胁。
Why did the police threaten you?
警察为什么要威胁你？
Oh, if we get loud and all this kind of stuff, they going to put us to jail. If we have any problems, they going to put us in jail and all. Man, come on. Give us a break. Man, give us a break. If we get loud, we not going to let you holler at us. Well, I feel like screaming. What you mean, holler at you? I could scream to the top of my-- do  he understand the pressure I'm under? Well, right now, mister, you holding me up right now, because the people-- I'm getting in line.
哦，如果我们大声说话之类的，他们就把我们关进监狱。如果我们有任何问题，他们就把我们关进监狱。伙计，拜托。给我们留条活路吧。伙计，给我们留条活路吧。如果我们要大声说话，我们不会让你对我们吼叫的。好吧，我想尖叫。你什么意思，吼你？我可以尖叫到我的——他明白我承受的压力吗？好吧，现在，先生，你正在阻碍我，因为那些人——我正在排队。
Ida Mae goes to stand in another line, the line to sign up for tomorrow's line, which turns out to be the wrong line. A volunteer points her in the right direction.
艾达·梅去排另一条队，那条是去排明天的队，结果那排错了。一名志愿者给她指了正确的方向。
Excuse me ma'am, the two-bedroom line is this line. There is the four-bedroom. I am sorry, OK? It was confusing, yeah. Thank you.
打扰一下女士，两居室的队伍在这边。那是四居室的。我很抱歉，好吗？这确实很令人困惑。谢谢。
I don't know what happened. As soon as they walk in in the morning, we're getting buses, and we're taking people out to their homes. It is a success story beyond their imagination that you may need to print or say something about on radio.
我不知道发生了什么。他们每天早上进来，我们就找来大巴，把人带到他们的住所去。这是一个超出他们想象的成功故事，你们可能需要打印出来或者在电台上说点什么。
This is Guy Rankin, the man with the unenviable job of running this place. When I stumble on to him in the middle of the arena, he says things are actually going pretty well here, and he means it.
这是盖伊·兰金（Guy Rankin），那个负责管理这个地方，工作吃力不讨好的人。当我在竞技场中间偶遇他时，他说这里的情况实际上进展得相当顺利，而且他是认真的。
There  were 25,000 people that are in dome. Now we're down to 3,000. They had to go somewhere. We housed most of them. We had 3,144 people taken to housing over the last five to seven days right off the dome floor. 800 seniors we took right off the dome floor, provided transportation, social services, and a full aspect of training, nurses, doctors, and all of that. I just got back--
巨蛋里有25000人。现在我们剩下3000人。他们必须去某个地方。我们安置了其中大部分人。在过去五到七天里，有3144人直接从巨蛋地板上被带走去安置。我们直接从巨蛋带走了800名老年人，提供了交通、社会服务、以及全面的培训、护士、医生等等。我刚回来——
If all these numbers don't quite match up to the chaos around us, it's for a reason. The housing voucher program, like so much of the Katrina aid, is a work in progress, being assembled on the fly. At first, when hurricane victims showed up, they were told to sign up, and then they'd be called when housing came available for them. Lots of people never got calls. And because that system was moving too slowly, it was changed midstream.
如果所有这些数字与我们周围的混乱不太吻合，那是有原因的。住房凭证计划，就像卡特里娜飓风援助的大部分工作一样，是一项正在进行中的工作，是临时拼凑起来的。起初，当飓风受害者出现时，他们被告知报名，然后在住房可用时会接到通知。许多人从来没接到过电话。由于系统运行太慢，它在中途进行了更改。
Now how it works is what we're seeing today. People come to the housing center and wait for buses that will take them directly to the apartments that had been chosen for them. But the system is still messy. Ida Mae, for instance, needed a three-bedroom apartment, and not enough of those were ready today.
现在它的工作方式就是我们今天看到的。人们来到住房中心，等待大巴直接将他们送到为他们挑选的公寓。但系统仍然很混乱。比如艾达·梅需要一套三居室公寓，而今天准备好的不够多。
But the one- and two-bedrooms, we didn't have enough people to fill the one- and two-bedrooms. It was empty. I know, I see that look on your face, but we've been housing people day after day, minute after minute, taking buses out, full buses. Those are the stories you need to tell the world, and what we're housing, and those are the units you need to go see.
但一居室和两居室，我们没有足够的人填满。它们空着。我知道，我看到你脸上的表情了，但我们每天、每分钟都在安置人们，开出大巴，满载的大巴。那些才是你们需要告诉世界的故事，我们正在安置什么，那些才是你们需要去看看的单位。
Well, how can we come out and see some of it? I know there was a bus just leaving now that we were hoping we might come along on.
好吧，我们怎么能去看看其中一些呢？我知道刚才刚好有一辆大巴要出发，我们希望能跟着去。
Yeah, you missed the bus.
是的，你们错过了那辆车。
Did I?
是吗？
Yeah.
是的。
All right, I'm going to call y'all when I make it in and I know how it looks. They told me they are lovely. It's the Timber Ridge Apartments.
好吧，当我到了那里，知道它看起来怎么样的时候，我会打给你们的。他们告诉我它们很可爱。那是廷伯岭公寓（Timber Ridge Apartments）。
As it turned out, the bus he said we missed was running late, and we caught the last one just as it was loading. The people lined up didn't really know where they were going, just that they'd have an apartment when they got there. There were seven families, mostly couples, one little boy, and a very, very pregnant woman named [? Lashawn ?] Price who said she didn't want to have to bring a new baby back to the Astrodome. I ask her when she's due, and she says any day, which turns out to be an understatement.
事实证明，他说我们错过的那辆车晚点了，我们正好赶上最后一辆车装载时上去了。排队的人其实不知道他们要去哪，只知道到了那里就会有公寓。有七个家庭，大多数是夫妇，一个小男孩，还有一个非常非常怀孕的女人叫拉肖恩·普莱斯（Lashawn Price），她说她不想把新生儿带回阿斯托巨蛋。我问她预产期是什么时候，她说随时可能，这显然是个轻描淡写的说法。
Do you have a doctor here or anything?
你有医生在这里之类的吗？
No, I'm too far along to get a health care doctor. I just have to wait it out.
没有，我怀得太久了，看不了医疗医生。我只能等着。
And they'll just tell you to go to the ER when you go into labor?
他们只会让你阵痛时去急诊室？
Yeah, I'm already three centimeters, so I'm just waiting on the next centimeter.
是的，我已经开了三指了，所以我在等下一指。
You're in labor.
你在阵痛中。
But they can't keep me until I'm four.
但他们不能留我到四指。
We all get on the bus. Lashawn, still completely calm, is having contractions at this point, and the housing official who's coming with us hands out the voucher forms. We drive for a while on the freeway, and people are starting to get nervous. We seemed really far from the Astrodome. Finally, after 45 minutes, we get there.
我们都上了大巴。拉肖恩此时仍然非常平静，开始宫缩，随行的一名住房官员分发了凭证表格。我们在高速公路上行驶了一会儿，人们开始紧张起来。我们看起来离阿斯托巨蛋真的很远。最终，45分钟后，我们到了。
Is this it? [CHEERING]
是这里吗？（欢呼）
It's a nice-looking townhouse development, with garages and tidy landscaping and new brick and siding. And for the first time all day, there's a sense that things are getting better.
这是一个看起来不错的联排别墅开发项目，有车库、整洁的景观，还有新的砖块和壁板。这是整天以来第一次感到事情正在好转。
Boy, we got lucky. We got lucky. We got so lucky, because they have to [INAUDIBLE]
天哪，我们真幸运。我们真幸运。我们太幸运了，因为他们必须（语音不清）
Well, the inside looks very, very beautiful.
好吧，里面看起来非常非常漂亮。
We're in the clubhouse now. It's big, kind of like the lobby of a Hampton Inn, and there's a loveseat and wingback chairs and a fancy flower arrangement on the front table. Out the back through the glass doors, you can see a pool and basketball courts. The families line up as if out of habit. They all stand there looking around, flipping through the brochures. A few minutes go by, a few more. In the back corner of the room are two young women. They obviously work there, and they see we're here, but they don't come up to us or even say hello. They're talking about what to do, and everyone knows it. And [? Lashawn ?] says what everyone's thinking.
我们现在在会所里。它很大，有点像汉普顿酒店（Hampton Inn）的大厅，有双人沙发、翼背椅，前桌上还有精致的花艺摆设。穿过玻璃门往后面看，可以看到一个游泳池和篮球场。各家庭习惯性地排起队。他们全都站在那里四处张望，翻阅手册。几分钟过去了，又几分钟。房间后角坐着两个年轻女性。她们显然在那里工作，看到我们在那，但她们没有走过来，甚至没有打招呼。她们在谈论该怎么做，每个人都知道。拉肖恩说出了大家心里想的话。
Is there a problem?
有问题吗？
But the women don't hear her, and the waiting continues. Finally, after 15 minutes, one of them comes forward. She's the assistant manager, though she doesn't introduce herself. She asks everyone to get out their social security cards and birth certificates, and she gets some incredulous looks.
但那两个女人没听见她的话，等待继续。最终，15分钟后，其中一个走上前来。她是助理经理，虽然她没有自我介绍。她要求每个人拿出社保卡和出生证明，她得到了一些怀疑的目光。
I don't have a social security card. We just came from a flood in New Orleans. Where are  you going to put that at? That's just so stupid.
我没有社保卡。我们刚从新奥尔良的洪水里逃出来。你要我把它放哪儿？这太愚蠢了。
She hands out the applications. Everyone can get an apartment tonight, she says, as long as they have no previous evictions and a clean criminal record. There's an awkward silence in the room, and then the questions begin.
她分发了申请表。她说，只要他们没有以前被驱逐的记录且犯罪记录清白，今晚每个人都能得到一套公寓。房间里出现了尴尬的沉默，然后问题开始了。
So if the people have a bad criminal check, they just have to be homeless?
所以如果这些人有犯罪记录，他们就必须无家可归吗？
If you know that you have a criminal background, and when I say criminal background, I mean no felonies whatsoever, no matter what it is or how old they are, misdemeanors for any drug-related, sex-related crime, or violence against person or property. So that's what I mean by criminal. So if those four things do not apply to you, or if you do not have an eviction, or if you do not owe a property any money, then yes, you will be in.
如果你知道自己有犯罪背景，我说犯罪背景是指没有任何重罪，无论是什么内容或多久以前，任何毒品、性相关犯罪或对人身或财产的暴力行为的轻罪。所以这就是我说的犯罪。如果这四项不适用于你，或者如果你没有被驱逐记录，或者如果你不欠任何房东钱，那么是的，你就会入住。
[? Lashawn ?] turns to me.
拉肖恩转向我。
This is BS. This is straight--
这简直是胡扯。这简直是——
Do you have one?
你有犯罪记录吗？
Do I have a conviction? Yeah, I have a conviction.
我有定罪记录吗？是的，我有定罪。
But a felony or misdemeanor?
但是重罪还是轻罪？
It's a felony, but it still doesn't stop me from working. I picked up a charge for my sister. That's not fair.
是重罪，但这并不影响我工作。我为我姐姐背了个罪名。这不公平。
Now it's getting really tense. The Housing Department guy is arguing with the assistant manager. People are pulling out their cell phones. There's some yelling. In a way, it's no different than things have been for weeks now. The rules keep changing, and no one tells them, and nothing ends up quite how it's supposed to be.
现在气氛变得非常紧张。住房部门的那个家伙在和助理经理争论。人们掏出手机。有一些叫喊声。从某种程度上说，这和过去几周的情况没什么不同。规则一直在变，没人告诉他们，事情的结果也没一样是按预期发展的。
Remember last week, when the big story was the FEMA debit cards? Some people got them, others didn't. Next to me, [? Lashawn's ?] getting more agitated by the minute. I can't believe she's not four centimeters dilated by now. Her old life, with her own apartment and her job as a medical records assistant, seems as far away as ever.
还记得上周吗？当时大新闻是FEMA的借记卡？有些人得到了，有些人没有。我旁边，拉肖恩变得越来越激动。我不相信她现在还没开四指。她以前的生活，有自己的公寓，还有作为医疗记录助理的工作，感觉离她越来越远。
That's the part that you're about to go insane behind. You're not in your right frame of mind no more, because if you think about everywhere you go, you're standing in the line for six, seven damn hours to get up there for somebody to give the damn runaround. After a while, it's starting to be-- then you can't even go home to somewhere and relax. You're going back to the damn center with 15,000, 20,000 people in it. You can't even sit out and have a peace of mind for a second.
那就是让你快要疯掉的部分。你不再处于正常的精神状态了，因为如果你想到你去任何地方，都要排队六、七个该死的小时，然后被人家踢皮球。过了一段时间，就开始了——然后你甚至不能回到某个地方去放松一下。你又回到了那个有1.5万、2万人该死的中心。你甚至不能坐下来安宁片刻。
I wish I had an answer for it myself right now, but I don't.
我希望我现在自己就有答案，但我没有。
Lisa, the assistant manager, seems a little overwhelmed.
丽莎，那个助理经理，看起来有点不堪重负。
And basically what happened is that they were supposed to be here earlier in the day, and they came five minutes before we were supposed to close. And then the bus driver's giving them 15 minutes to get back on the bus, and that's just not adequate time enough for us to be able to get them in and out. I feel really bad.
基本上发生的情况是，他们本应在白天早些时候到达，但他们在我们预定关门前五分钟才到。然后大巴司机只给他们15分钟时间回车上，这根本不足以让我们能让他们进进出出。我觉得非常糟糕。
A regional manager shows up, promising to help people, but it's too late. Everyone feels discriminated against. Here's [? Lashawn ?] and another woman as they get back on the bus.
一位区域经理出现，承诺帮助人们，但已经太晚了。每个人都感到受到歧视。这是拉肖恩和另一个女人上回大巴时的情况。
Them bastards looked at us like we was misfits, and y'all negroes ain't getting in here.
那帮混蛋把我们当成异类，你们这些黑人别想进这来。
That's not right
这不对。
You're coming from nowhere. You have nothing. They know you don't have nothing. And then for you to turn around and try to makeshift throw little stepping stones in front of you like that? That's not right. That's not right.
你们一无所有。他们知道你们一无所有。然后你们竟然转过身来，试图在那样设置绊脚石？这不对。这不对。
The housing official, he's back on the bus too, tells me he doesn't know why this has happened. It's his first day, he says. But there's another complex open tonight which also accepts the vouchers.
那个住房官员也回到了车上，告诉我他不知道为什么会发生这种情况。他说这是他的第一天。但今晚还有另一个公寓区开放，也接受凭证。
So the bus gets back on the freeway and drives to a neighborhood on the northwest side of the city. Out the bus windows, more and more of the store names are in Spanish. Someone spots a man pedaling a little food cart, and a bunch of people snicker. By the time the bus stops in front of a weathered two-story apartment complex called Villa del Sol, most of the passengers seem a little freaked out. One thing's for sure: this isn't Timber Ridge. For starters, when we get inside they're ready for us.
大巴回到高速公路上，开往城市西北部的一个社区。车窗外，越来越多的商店名称是用西班牙语写的。有人发现一个骑着食品车的人，一群人窃笑。当大巴停在叫“太阳别墅”（Villa del Sol）的风化两层公寓大楼前时，大多数乘客似乎有点吓坏了。有一点是肯定的：这不是廷伯岭。起初，当我们进入里面时，他们已经为我们准备好了。
We have a really nice kids center here.
我们这里有一个非常好的儿童中心。
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
（听不清）
We have a great kids center here that has five new computers in it.
我们这里有一个很棒的儿童中心，里面有五台新电脑。
We crowd into the rental office. It's more basement rec room than Hampton Inn, with mismatched furniture and no slick brochures. But it's clean and comfortable, and a table in the center of the room is piled high with food: pizzas, sodas, chips. Pick as much as you want, people are saying. On the wall is a photo collage: the neighborhood kids at summer day camp.
我们涌入租赁办公室。比起汉普顿酒店，这里更像是地下室的娱乐室，家具不匹配，也没有花哨的手册。但它干净舒适，房间中心的桌子上堆满了食物：比萨饼、苏打水、薯片。想拿多少就拿多少，人们说。墙上是一张照片拼贴画：暑期夏令营的社区孩子们。
It's a big party. I'm going to need your initials right here please.
这是一个大派对。我需要你们在这签个首字母，拜托。
Lashawn sits down at the manager's desk and picks up a pen. She looks exhausted.
拉肖恩坐在经理办公桌旁拿起笔。她看起来精疲力竭。
And right here, right there, one more, right there too, and I'm going to need your signature here.
就在这儿，就在那儿，再来一个，就在那儿，我还得需要你的签名在这儿。
It was that simple. She had an apartment, six months rent free.
就是这么简单。她有了一套公寓，六个月免租金。
So how were you feeling while you were writing that?
那你写这些的时候感觉如何？
I don't know. It's just, whatever. Whatever. It's got a roof and a door, and I can sanitize it and have a new baby. That's all I'm looking for now.
我不知道。就是，随便吧。随便吧。它有屋顶和门，我可以打扫干净，生个新宝宝。这就是我现在想要的一切。
No one else from our group even fills out the paperwork. They eat the pizza and drift back to the bus. They'll find something better, they say. I grab one of them.
我们团组里没人再填那些文书了。他们吃着比萨，飘回大巴。他们说会找到更好的。我抓住其中一个。
Can I ask you why you don't want to stay?
我能问你为什么不想留下来吗？
Why I'm not staying? Because look how far we are from here. Just look around you. You see yourself. Ain't no good environment. Mexicans are the only people around here.
我为什么不留下来？因为看看我们离这里多远。环顾四周吧。你自己看看。这不是个好环境。这里周围只有墨西哥人。
It's hard to miss the fact that some of the same people who were complaining the loudest about discrimination at Timber Ridge were the quickest to say they didn't want to live around a bunch of Mexicans. One of them told me later, if you were in our shoes, wouldn't you feel out of place? It's a different community, a community you're not a part of. Our kids might get picked on or ridiculed. They'll be outsiders.
很难忽视一个事实，即一些在廷伯岭投诉歧视最响亮的人，却最快表示不想住在一群墨西哥人周围。其中一个人后来告诉我，如果你处于我们的处境，难道不会觉得格格不入吗？这是一个不同的社区，一个你并不属于的社区。我们的孩子可能会被欺负或嘲笑。他们会是局外人。
You've got a kid, right?
你有孩子，对吧？
Yeah.
是的。
Laura Rodriguez, the assistant manager, is going to give [? Lashawn ?] a tour. Jane, my co-producer, walks over to the apartment with them, and halfway there [? Lashawn ?] grabs Jane's hand.
劳拉·罗德里格斯（Laura Rodriguez），助理经理，要带拉肖恩参观。我的联合制片人简陪着她们去了公寓，在半路上，拉肖恩抓住了简的手。
Going to feel a contraction? You're having one?
感觉要宫缩了吗？你正在宫缩？
Yeah.
是的。
Now?
现在？
[LABORED WHISTLING]
（费力的呼吸声）
This is your apartment. This is a two-bedroom apartment, and one bath. It's real nice. It has a walk-in closet. Let me show you. They're nice and big. You can fit a bed in there. I think you're going to be happy here. People here are very friendly. I've been in this property for five years. People is nice.
这是你的公寓。这是一套两居室公寓，带一个卫生间。真的很不错。它有一个步入式衣橱。让我给你看看。它们又大又好。你可以放下一张床。我想你会喜欢这里的。这里的人非常友好。我在这处房产已经五年了。人们很好。
It's nice. I'm glad. Thank you.
很好。我很开心。谢谢。
To their credit, the people running this housing program are still working on it, still adjusting it each day, still trying to figure out how to get more people into apartments more quickly. The next morning, we go back to the housing center. Things are a lot the same.
值得称赞的是，运行这个住房计划的人们仍在努力，每天都在调整，仍在尝试寻找如何更快地将更多人带入公寓的方法。第二天早上，我们回到住房中心。情况和之前差不多。
Telling us to come back tomorrow. I was here yesterday with my proof. This is my proof. I was here yesterday.
告诉我们明天再来。我昨天带着证明在这了。这是我的证明。我昨天就在这。
I try to talk to Guy Rankin, the guy in charge, but he's busy. He's walking around the arena, going from section to section with a bullhorn, listening to people's complaints and trying to answer their questions.
我试图和盖伊·兰金谈谈，那个负责人，但他很忙。他正在竞技场周围走动，拿着扩音器从一个区走到另一个区，倾听人们的投诉并试图回答他们的问题。
But let me first explain the Housing Choice Center. Some of you may have heard it before, but we need to do it again for everybody who's here.
但我先解释一下“住房选择中心”。你们中的一些人可能以前听过，但对于这里的每个人，我们需要再做一次。
The system's still got some problems. Lots of people are asking why they just can't rent their own apartments with the voucher money instead of taking the places chosen for them in neighborhoods they don't know and don't feel comfortable with. It might sound picky, but when I talked to a New Orleans mom whose son has already started elementary school here and is happy there and doesn't want to move again, I'm reminded of how complicated this all is.
该系统仍然存在一些问题。许多人在问为什么他们不能用凭证钱自己租公寓，而不是接受为他们挑选的那些他们不了解也不觉得舒服的社区。这听起来可能很挑剔，但当我与一位新奥尔良的母亲交谈时，她的儿子已经在这里开始了小学生活，很开心，不想再搬家了，我想起了这一切是多么复杂。
I listen for a while to Rankin. He tells the crowd he's heard that complaint, and that maybe soon there will be a way to let people choose their own places. It's still being worked out, he says, even as he speaks. Later today, he says, there might even be a line for that.
我听了兰金一会儿。他告诉人群他已经听到了那个投诉，也许很快就会有一种让人们选择自己住所的方法。他说这正在制定中，即使在他说话的时候。他说今天晚些时候，甚至可能有一条专门为那个设立的队伍。
That system will be set up today, and we'll be lining up for that, lining up for that. I can only take one more question from this group, and please be patient with us, because we're very, very busy. I know you've been here 17 days. Some of us have been here 17 days with 20 hours a day. I'm going to answer each of your questions.
那个系统今天就会建立，我们将会为那个排队，排队。我只能回答这个群体的最后一个问题，请对我们保持耐心，因为我们非常非常忙。我知道你们已经在这里待了17天了。我们有些人已经在这里待了17天，每天20个小时。我会回答你们的每一个问题。
Lisa Pollak. In the few days since the middle of the week when she left the housing center, they've made other improvements, like they've given people wristbands to keep their place in line. The biggest hold-up is still finding acceptable apartments, inspecting them, and then getting people out to see them. That will continue to be slow, especially for people who want three-, and four-, and five-bedroom apartments, which are scarce. By Friday, the number of families that the city had put into the six-month free apartments had climbed from 3,100 to 4,800.
丽莎·波拉克。从周中她离开住房中心后的几天里，他们做了其他改进，比如他们给人们发了腕带以保持排队位置。最大的障碍仍然是寻找可接受的公寓，检查它们，然后让人出去看它们。那将继续缓慢，特别是对于那些想要三居、四居和五居公寓的人，它们非常稀缺。到周五，城市放入六个月免费公寓的家庭数量已经从3100个增加到4800个。
Right outside the housing center, on the parking lot between the Astrodome and the Reliant Center, the YMCA set up a huge recreation area for kids and adults. Basketball courts. There's blow-up things that little kids bounce on at fairs. There's one tent of arcade video machines, and Dance Dance Revolution for kids, and a second tent of arcade games for adults, all set up so no quarters were needed. On one machine I saw a message that I had never seen before: game never over.
就在住房中心外面，阿斯托巨蛋和莱里安特中心之间的停车场上，基督教青年会（YMCA）为儿童和成人建立了一个巨大的娱乐区。篮球场。有小孩子们在集市上蹦跳的充气设备。有一个帐篷是街机视频游戏机，还有给孩子玩的《跳舞机》（Dance Dance Revolution），第二个帐篷是给成人玩的街机游戏，所有这一切都不需要硬币。在一台机器上，我看到了一个我从未见过的消息：游戏永不结束。
At a plastic table in the tent, two kids have drumsticks, and one was teaching the other how to play. Volunteers from Seattle and North Carolina and all over the place walked through, tending the kids and chatting happily like they'd known each other for years. On the Ms. Pac-Man machine, I see a man take a break from standing in line for government help by playing the fastest, greatest game of Ms. Pac-Man I have ever witnessed in my life.
在帐篷里的一张塑料桌子旁，两个孩子拿着鼓槌，一个正在教另一个怎么玩。来自西雅图、北卡罗来纳州和世界各地的志愿者走来走去，照顾着孩子，开心地聊天，就像认识了多年一样。在《吃豆人》（Ms. Pac-Man）机器上，我看到一个人在排队等待政府帮助时休息一下，玩了一把我有生以来见过的最快、最棒的《吃豆人》。
Yeah, when I was at my house in New Orleans, yeah, I used to play it on my TV. So I got a little bit of skills behind this thing.
是的，我在新奥尔良家里的时候，是的，我曾经在电视上玩过。所以我对这东西有点技术。
Outside, a cool late afternoon breeze starts to kick in, and I watch as a pediatric doctor in scrubs, a volunteer who flew in from Baltimore, tries to cross the playground, and gets stopped first by a six-year-old who has to borrow the doctor's camera to take her picture.
外面，凉爽的午后微风开始吹起来，我看着一名身穿刷手服的儿科医生，一个从巴尔的摩飞来的志愿者，试图穿过操场，被一个六岁的女孩拦住，她必须借医生的相机来给她拍张照。
You know how to  do it now right, because you're a professional photographer? Let me fix it for you.
你知道现在怎么拍了吧，因为你是个专业摄影师？让我帮你调一下。
And then she lends her cell phone to an older girl who needs to call a parent, even though she's having trouble.
然后她把手机借给一个需要给家长打电话的稍大的女孩，尽管她遇到了一些麻烦。
It's his phone.
这是他的手机。
Do you want to try it again? Same number? Is it not ringing?
你想再试一次吗？同一个号码？没响吗？
823--
823——
As the sun started to go down on Tuesday, it was hard to believe that this whole complex would soon be gone, this city built in a day, like Brigadoon. 27,000 people were just two weeks ago, down to a few thousand this week. The past few weeks have been horrific for people here, traumatic, and the next six months are going to be incredibly hard, too, as people set up new lives, and homes, and jobs. This place was a waystation where sometimes it was possible to pause and rest.
当太阳在周二落下时，很难相信整个这个综合大楼很快就会消失，这个在一天之内建立起来的城市，就像《布里加多恩》（Brigadoon）一样。两周前还有27000人，本周下降到几千人。过去几周对这里的人来说是可怕的、创伤性的，接下来的六个月也将极其艰难，因为人们在建立新的生活、家园和工作。这个地方是一个休息站，有时可以停下来休息一下。
[MUSIC - "PROMISED LAND" BY CHUCK BERRY]
（音乐——查克·贝里的《应许之地》）
Coming up: yes, the streets of New Orleans are still restricted. So what's it like to drive around there right now? That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
即将到来：是的，新奥尔良的街道仍然受到限制。那么现在在那里开车是什么感觉？那将在来自芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台的节目继续中，在一分钟内为您呈现。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme and bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, This is not My Beautiful House, stories about the hundreds of thousands of people sent into exodus since Hurricane Katrina. We've arrived at Act Four of our show. Act Four The Long Way Home.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。当然，每周在我们的节目中，我们都会选择一个主题，并为您带来各种关于该主题的不同故事。今天的节目，《这不是我美丽的家》，关于飓风卡特里娜以来被送入大迁徙的数十万人的故事。我们来到了节目的第四幕。第四幕，回家的长路。
Well, the mayor of New Orleans has announced that this weekend certain parts of New Orleans will reopen, first to business owners and then to residents, this weekend and in the coming week. Nick Spitzer is part of the New Orleans diaspora. He's also the host of the Public Radio International music show, American Routes. He's living now with his wife and his two little kids in Lafayette, living with friends. He has a press pass, so it's actually been legal for him to drive through the city of New Orleans. The streets are restricted, of course. So he finally tried it.
好吧，新奥尔良市长已经宣布，本周末新奥尔良的某些部分将重新开放，首先是商业业主，然后是居民，本周末和下周。尼克·斯皮策是新奥尔良侨民的一部分。他也是国际公共广播电台音乐节目《美国路线》（American Routes）的主持人。他现在和妻子以及两个小孩住在拉斐特（Lafayette），住在这里的朋友家。他有新闻证，所以开车穿过新奥尔良对他来说在法律上是合法的。当然，街道受到限制。所以他最终尝试了一次。
This is, I think it's September the 7th. It is September the 7th, in downtown New Orleans, sitting on Canal Street right now inside my car. I'm about to take a ride uptown, and I'm just going to narrate what I see as I go.
我想现在是9月7日。今天是9月7日，在新奥尔良市中心，现在坐在运河街（Canal Street）的我的车里。我准备乘车去住宅区，我只是要叙述我所看到的一切。
So I've been told to go by way of Tchoupitoulas Street, and I'm told that it's fairly clear going up Tchoupitoulas. It makes sense. It's the old high ground in the city. So here we go. Certainly there are a lot of security guards everywhere who aren't very friendly, lots of guys in black with Kevlar vests and different things that say Security ICE, and security this, and security that. And then of course there's just the good old garden variety New Orleans cops. And then there's cops from all over, which is really, really strange: cops from Dublin, Ohio, cops from New Mexico.
所以有人告诉我经由Tchoupitoulas街走，我被告知去Tchoupitoulas街是很畅通的。这很有道理。这是城市里的古老高地。所以我们走吧。当然，到处都是保安，他们不太友好，很多穿黑色衣服的人戴着凯夫拉背心，还有各种写着“安全移民海关执法局”（ICE）、“安全这个”、“安全那个”的东西。然后当然还有老派的新奥尔良警察。而且还有来自各地的警察，这真的很奇怪：来自俄亥俄州都柏林的警察，来自新墨西哥州的警察。
I'm going to see-- there's no traffic lights working. I think I'm going to cut through here. I think I can do it. Yes, I can do it. And I'm off and running. And no one's shooting at me, for which I'm thankful. There's a guy with a machine gun there. I think actually there's a corpse up this way. Somebody told me.
我看看——没有交通灯在工作。我想我可以在这穿过。我想我可以做到。是的，我可以做到。我出发了。没人对我开枪，对此我很感激。那儿有一个拿着机枪的家伙。我想其实那边有一具尸体。有人告诉我。
I'm heading up Tchoupitoulas Street here. Everywhere you turn there's just garbage lying everywhere, garbage and old signs. There's electric generators running on diesel. Place reeks of diesel in addition to the smell of corpses and dead animals and rotting vegetation, and this stinking water everywhere, just oil, toxic crap.
我正沿着Tchoupitoulas街向上走。到处都是垃圾，到处都是垃圾和旧标志。有靠柴油运行的发电机。这地方除了尸体、死动物和腐烂植被的气味外，还散发着柴油味，到处都是这种发臭的水，只是油、有毒的垃圾。
Boy, here we are on St. Joseph and Commerce, and there's just garbage in all directions. Shopping carts-- oh, this must be where all the looting took place. That's exactly what this is. Oh, it is so strange and so sad.
天哪，我们现在在圣约瑟夫街和商业街，到处都是垃圾。购物车——噢，这一定是抢劫发生的地方。这正是它的样子。噢，它真是太奇怪、太悲伤了。
There's the D-Day Museum. Jeez, looks like they've looted the D-Day museum. That is really strange, looting the gift shop of the D-Day museum.
那是二战博物馆（D-Day Museum）。天哪，看起来他们抢劫了二战博物馆。这真的很奇怪，抢劫二战博物馆的礼品店。
This really smells bad out here. Unfortunately, it's because there are quite a few bodies over there by the edge of the Convention Center. Oh God, this is just awful.
这里闻起来真的很糟糕。不幸的是，因为会议中心边缘有相当多的尸体。噢，上帝，这真是太可怕了。
Now we're heading uptown on Tchoupitoulas. Jeez, I've got to be careful for these tires, too, now that I think about it. I do have another tire back there, but I'm told there's a lot of roof tacks in the street. There's a lot of glass everywhere, a lot of metal shards, and just the streets are in bad, bad, bad shape.
现在我们沿着Tchoupitoulas街前往住宅区。天哪，我现在得小心这些轮胎，想到这个。我后面确实有备胎，但我被告知街上有很多屋顶钉子。到处都是玻璃，很多金属碎片，街道状况非常、非常、非常糟糕。
Wow, there's people walking. Maybe I can even talk to--
哇，有人在走路。也许我甚至可以和——
Hey man, how you doing? So you working with?
嘿伙计，你怎么样？所以你和谁一起工作？
FEMA, FEMA. We was working across the river today. As you can see, we cleared up all of St. Charles. We cleared out all Louisiana. We clearing up everywhere. We're just cleaning up, man. And it's giving me something to do, keep me from thinking about my family most, sitting down, just concentrating on doing something constructive.
FEMA，FEMA。我们今天在河对面工作。如你所见，我们清理了查尔斯街。我们清理了整个路易斯安那州。我们到处都在清理。我们只是在清理，伙计。这给了我一些事情做，让我不用一直想我的家人，坐着，只是集中精力做一些有建设性的事情。
I've found that by putting your mind on work, you don't feel bad about anything else going on.
我发现通过把心思放在工作上，你就不会对正在发生的其他事情感到糟糕。
They was trying to run us out of the houses and stuff, talking about evacuating. But why shall I leave? They got people coming in from out of town working. I talked to a guy before I got the job where I'm working at now. This guy was from Houston, Texas, a temporary worker working on it. Why the citizens that live here can't stay down here and work? It doesn't make sense. They got so much money coming up.
他们试图把我们赶出房子，谈论撤离。但我为什么要离开？他们有从外地来的人在工作。我得到现在的工作之前和一个家伙谈过。那个家伙来自德克萨斯州休斯顿，是个在那工作的临时工。为什么住在这里的市民不能待在这里工作？这说不通。他们有那么多钱进来。
Let the locals rebuild the city.
让当地人重建城市。
Yeah, let the locals rebuild it. And he want to run us out.
是的，让当地人重建它。而他想把我们赶走。
And then, I didn't want to leave this animal here to die. I didn't want her to die. I didn't want to leave her out on the street to get hit or none of that. I couldn't leave her, and my daughters never would have forgiven me. When they come home, Lord blessed me to still be here, I'm going to surprise them. I'm going to hide that dog. I'm going to say, Destiny gone. I couldn't keep her. And I'm going to come out with her. And I know how they're going to feel. I know how they going-- I got it all planned too. I'm going to see my family again.
然后，我不想让这只动物留在这里死掉。我不想让它死。我不想把它留在大街上被撞之类的。我不能丢下它，我的女儿们永远不会原谅我。当她们回家时，上帝保佑我还能待在这里，我会给她们惊喜。我会把那条狗藏起来。我会说，Destiny丢了。我留不住它。然后我会带着它出来。我知道她们会有什么感觉。我知道她们——我都计划好了。我会再次见到我的家人的。
When do you think you'll get your family back in town?
你觉得你什么时候能让你的家人回来？
Oh, I don't know. They're talking about like two to three months, something like that. It's going to be really hard, because I shed a few tears because I miss them, but I know they in a better place than where I'm at. But I don't know where they at. I don't know where anyone at.
噢，我不知道。他们在谈论比如两到三个月之类的。那将是非常困难的，因为我流了几滴泪，因为我想念她们，但我知道她们待的地方比我待的地方好。但我不知道她们在哪里。我不知道任何人都在哪里。
And you can't even talk to them.
你甚至不能和她们说话。
I can't even talk to my mother. She left before the storm. The day before the storm she was in Mississippi. I haven't talked to her since.
我甚至不能和我母亲说话。她在风暴前离开了。风暴前一天她在密西西比州。从那以后我没和她说过话。
Well, you take care, man. It's a pleasure to talk to you.
好吧，你保重，伙计。和你谈话很愉快。
You have a safe trip. Watch yourself, because the army people just told me they got some bad guys running around.
你也一路平安。小心点，因为军队的人刚告诉我他们附近有一些坏家伙在游荡。
Running around uptown here?
在住宅区这儿游荡？
Yeah, he say they in the area.
是的，他说他们就在附近。
Guys with guns, huh?
拿着枪的家伙，哈？
Must be.
一定是。
I got to go a little further uptown. I hope I don't see any. Bye-bye.
我得再往住宅区走一点。希望我看不到任何一个。再见。
Hmm, those guys look a little suspicious in that truck. It's a little spooky up here. It's about 5:45 in the afternoon here, Wednesday afternoon.
嗯，卡车里的那些家伙看起来有点可疑。这儿有点毛骨悚然。现在大约是周三下午5点45分。
Coming up to the intersection of Tchoupitoulas and Napoleon, famous for the Tipitina's nightclub. I had heard there'd been some musicians sleeping here. I don't know what the deal is, though.
来到Tchoupitoulas街和拿破仑街（Napoleon）的十字路口，以Tipitina的夜总会闻名。我听说这里有一些音乐家在睡觉。我不知道情况怎么样。
Oh, here's a landmark: Hansen's Sno-Bliz, the snowball shop that I love so much. And it looks OK.
噢，这里有个地标：汉森雪花冰（Hansen's Sno-Bliz），我非常喜欢的雪球店。看起来还好。
Now I'm coming to Magazine Street, which is, of course, a major thoroughfare. I don't want them to think this microphone is a gun. There's some cops kind of eyeing me, but I'm going to wave to them. Hey, guys.
现在我到了Magazine街，当然，这是主要干道。我不希望他们认为这个麦克风是枪。有些警察在盯着我，但我会向他们挥手。嘿，伙计们。
See my house in the distance, just can barely see it in the distance now. There's a SUV going by it. Jeez, I'm kind of nervous just coming back, worried. A lot of trees down right near the house. Oh God, it's my house. Looks like one window might have blown down in the dining room, unless somebody busted in there. I don't know.
看到远处的我的房子了，现在几乎能在远处看到它。有一辆SUV经过它。天哪，我回来时有点紧张，担心。房子附近有很多树倒了。噢，上帝，那是我的房子。看起来餐厅的一扇窗户可能吹倒了，除非有人闯进去了。我不知道。
I'm going to go in the house with a-- drop the cargo. Go in the house with a flashlight. I got to be the first one back in the hood. This is really strange. There's those insects in the trees. It's so bloody quiet.
我要拿着一个——放下货物进房子。拿着手电筒进屋。我一定是社区里第一个回来的人。这真的很奇怪。树里有那些昆虫。安静得要死。
[KNOCKS] I don't think anybody's in here. I sure hope not. The alarm was left on. Doesn't look like anybody's been fooling with this place. Ooh, doesn't smell too good. Hello, anybody home? I always keep this little bell here by the door. [BELL CHIMES] Service.
（敲门声）我不认为里面有人。我真希望没有。警报一直开着。看起来没人动过这里。噢，闻起来不太好。你好，有人在家吗？我一直把这个小铃铛放在门口。（铃声响）服务。
It does smell a little bit of rotten food in here. I'm almost afraid to open the refrigerator, because it's been about-- Phew. Oh. Oh. Oh God, that will make you puke.
这里闻起来确实有一点腐烂食物的味道。我几乎不敢打开冰箱，因为它已经大约——呼。噢。噢。噢，上帝，那会让你呕吐。
We're back in the back downstairs bathroom. There's my little boy's stool. Gets up to wash his hands. Yeah, I heard the water was on, but--
我们回到了楼下的洗手间。那是我的小男孩的凳子。起来洗手。是的，我听说水开了，但——
The whole window is beautiful. The window pane is an ovular window pane with with stained glass. I'm just going to take the damn tape off. It saved it. Let's assume there won't be another hurricane here anytime soon.
整扇窗户都很漂亮。窗格是一块带有彩色玻璃的卵形窗格。我只是要把该死的胶带撕下来。它救了它。假设近期这里不会有另一场飓风吧。
I am so lucky. I am just so lucky. Real question is will we ever live here again. Let's go into my son's room. This is Perry's room. The doors seem to be sealed shut. It won't-- there it goes. This is his brother Gardner's room. He hasn't moved into it yet, because he's only four months old. And it looks like it's OK.
我真是太幸运了。我真是太幸运了。真正的问题是我们还能再住在这里吗。我们进我儿子的房间。这是佩里（Perry）的房间。门看起来封死了。它不会——有了。这是他哥哥加德纳（Gardner）的房间。他还没搬进去，因为他才四个月大。看起来还可以。
No one living here, and it's just incredibly sad. If I started thinking about it, I'd get upset. It's better just to keep moving, get the list, pack, and leave, I think, at this point. I don't want to stay here. It's too creepy. There's just nobody around for miles.
没有人住在这里，这真是令人难以置信的悲伤。如果我开始想这件事，我会很难过。我想现在最好继续前进，拿到名单，收拾行李离开。我不想待在这里。这里太令人毛骨悚然了。方圆几英里一个人都没有。
Margaret's given me a list here. Hope I can do all of it. Guest room, quilt on the guest bed: I got that. The LP records, jazz boxes, her Elvis Costello collection. I don't know if I can carry all that. In the bathroom downstairs, I'd better get that Wiggles towel for my son, Perry. He misses it. The scuzzy, I think it's called, or snuggly that goes into the jogger for little baby Gardner. Maybe I can get that jogger out. There's the old Mardi Gras flag, Muses flag. I don't know why she wants that. She didn't even ride that yet, but who knows? Thomas trains, videos, Dora, Ringling Brothers circus, and the little blue jacket.
玛格丽特给我列了一份清单。希望我能全做完。客房，客床上的被子：我拿到了。LP唱片，爵士乐盒，她的埃尔文·科斯特洛（Elvis Costello）收藏。我不知道我能不能全都带走。楼下的洗手间，我最好拿上我儿子佩里的Wiggles毛巾。他想它。我想是叫scuzzy，或者就是塞进那个婴儿慢跑车的Snuggly，给小宝宝加德纳的。也许我可以把那个慢跑车拿出来。那里有旧的Mardi Gras旗帜，Muses旗帜。我不知道她为什么想要那个。她还没坐过那个呢，但谁知道呢？托马斯火车，录像带，Dora，玲玲兄弟马戏团，还有那件小蓝夹克。
Upstairs in the sun room, all the memento boxes and pictures. Running shoes, Nine West shoes. I haven't even gotten anything on the list for me, but I'll figure it out.
楼上的日光室，所有的纪念盒和照片。跑鞋，Nine West鞋。我甚至还没给我拿到任何清单上的东西，但我会想办法的。
Just about got the last stuff in the car. Now I'm using the light of the tape recorder to find my flashlight.
差不多把最后的东西装进车里了。现在我用录音机的光来找我的手电筒。
Well, I'm back in the car. It's really dark. I feel like I've been a looter in my own house. I came to get possessions to last how long? A month? Two? Three? It's just hard to know what to take. You just take bits and pieces. It's like your whole life was just washing by you, and you feel like a cat burglar walking around, and every sound is pretty scary.
好吧，我回车上了。真的很黑。我觉得自己像是我家里的抢劫犯。我来拿财产要维持多久？一个月？两个？三个？很难知道该拿什么。你只是拿些点滴。就像你的一生都在你身边流逝，你感觉自己像个猫贼走来走去，每一个声音都相当吓人。
Well, I'm going to go back down to the compound for the night. So I'm all alone on St. Charles Avenue. It's very dark. It's like being on a country road going through the middle of a very big city. Yeah, here comes a car. He's turning across my bow. Let's see what this guy is. Let's hope we don't have a problem here. It's like a military kind of a guy. That's what they told me to be careful about was, when you come down the street, that if somebody turns in front of you in a large vehicle, they could block you. You've got to be really careful.
好吧，我要回大院待一晚。所以我独自走在圣查尔斯大街（St. Charles Avenue）上。非常黑。就像走在穿过大城市中心的一条乡村公路上。是的，那儿来了一辆车。他转弯穿过我的车头。看看这家伙是谁。希望我们这里没问题。他像个军队里的人。这就是他们告诉我必须小心的地方，当你沿街走时，如果有人在大车里转到你前面，他们可能会挡住你。你必须非常小心。
Hi, gentlemen.
嗨，先生们。
Don't come creeping up that fast again, OK?
别再那样鬼鬼祟祟地靠过来了，好吗？
Sorry, I didn't see you.
抱歉，我没看见你们。
That's fine. When somebody does that, you stop.
没关系。当有人那样做时，你停下。
Yes, sir.
是的，长官。
We don't know who you are.
我们不知道你是谁。
Yeah, I understand.
是的，我明白。
I appreciate that.
我感激这一点。
No problem.
没问题。
Seen anything that we need to know about around here?
有我们需要知道的任何情况吗？
Not really. I've been up at, basically, Prytania and Jefferson area, and I have not seen or heard a peep.
没有。我基本上一直在Prytania和杰斐逊地区（Jefferson area），我没有看到或听到任何动静。
All right, we appreciate it. Just be safe, all right?
好吧，我们感激这一点。注意安全，好吗？
Yeah, man.
是的，伙计。
Wow. Well that was fun. Those guys were on some kind of operation looking for the thieves, because they had all their lights down. And I don't think they were too happy that I showed up. Their guns were drawn. I think that jogging stroller up top probably makes me look pretty nondescript. They bought my story, anyway.
哇。好吧，那真好玩。那些家伙在执行某种寻找窃贼的行动，因为他们把灯都关了。我认为他们对我出现不太高兴。他们的枪都拔出来了。我想车顶上的那个慢跑车可能让我看起来相当不起眼。无论如何，他们相信了我的故事。
Now I'm cutting back over to Prytania, and there's a big rat crossing the street here. Oh, jeez [UNINTELLIGIBLE]. Oh, there's a kitty cat. Oh, that's so sad. He's alive, but barely. The animals are starving in this city.
现在我切回Prytania街，那里有一只大老鼠在过街。噢，天哪（听不清）。噢，有一只小猫。噢，那太悲伤了。他还活着，但几乎不行了。动物们在这个城市里快饿死了。
Nick Spitzer. You can hear his great music show, or find out what time it's on the radio, at www.americanroutes.org.
尼克·斯皮策。您可以在www.americanroutes.org上听到他的精彩音乐节目，或查明它在电台播放的时间。
[MUSIC - "DON'T EVER BE AFRAID TO GO HOME" BY FRANK SINATRA]
（音乐——弗兰克·辛纳屈的《永远不要害怕回家》）
Act Five, Water Bed. Well, we have one last story about homes and houses in New Orleans. Louann Mims is 78 years old, and never paid much attention to the annual hurricane and storm warnings in New Orleans where she lives. But this year, this year was different. The morning of August 29, the day the hurricane hit, she got everything ready to pack her car to go to the Superdome to take refuge from the incoming flood. From a temporary housing facility in Maywood, Illinois, where she is now, she talked to Alex Kotlowitz about that day.
第五幕，水床。好吧，我们有一个关于新奥尔良家园和房子的最后一个故事。卢安·米姆斯（Louann Mims）今年78岁，从未对她居住的新奥尔良的年度飓风和风暴警报给予太多关注。但今年，今年不同。8月29日早上，飓风袭来的那一天，她准备好了一切，打包车子去超级巨蛋躲避洪水。从她现在所在的伊利诺伊州梅伍德（Maywood）的临时住房设施，她向亚历克斯·科特洛维茨（Alex Kotlowitz）讲述了那一天。
I got up in the morning and I looked out, and it looked fairly ordinary. I said, well, I'm going to have a bowl of cereal and a banana. I put the cereal in and poured on the milk and had two bites, and I looked, and the water was just coming in from the patio. So I got up, looked to the front part of the house. Water was coming in the front door.
早上我起来看了一眼，看起来相当平常。我说，好吧，我要吃碗麦片和一个香蕉。我放了麦片，倒上牛奶，吃了两口，然后我看了看，水正从露台涌进来。所以我起来，看了看房子的前部。水正涌进前门。
Oh, my God, what do I do? But then it came so quickly, and within five to eight minutes there was almost five feet of water in the house. So I'm now, God, what am I going to do? And everything is floating. I sat on the top of the ladder, and I realized then it was getting a little later in the afternoon, and I had better just see if there was anything that I could sleep on that night, because I couldn't get out. I couldn't go walking in all this water.
噢，上帝，我该怎么办？但接着它来得太快了，五到八分钟内房子里就有近五英尺深的水。所以现在我，上帝，我该怎么办？所有东西都在漂。我坐在梯子顶上，那时我意识到天色渐晚，我最好看看今晚有没有什么东西可以睡，因为我出不去。我不能走在这些水里。
Your house is one story?
你的房子是一层的吗？
Uh-huh. It's a 10-room ranch. So I walked past the spare room, and the mattress is about to go under, so no sleeping on that one. I go to my bedroom, and my mattress was floating. I say, hey, I'll go get my ladder. I  can climb up there. And I did, and that's where I was for eight days and eight nights. And this mattress is a Stearns & Foster, and I had just received it the end of April. I bought the extra firm, so it must have a lot of wood in it.
嗯。这是一个10个房间的牧场式建筑。所以我走过备用房间，床垫快要沉下去了，所以那个不能睡。我去我的卧室，我的床垫在漂。我说，嘿，我去拿我的梯子。我可以爬到上面去。我做了，那是我在那儿待了八天八夜的地方。这个床垫是Stearns & Foster牌的，我四月底刚收到它。我买了超硬款，所以它肯定含有很多木材。
So you're sitting, you're floating on your mattress. King size or--?
所以你在坐，你在你的床垫上漂。特大号的还是——？
A queen size.
女王号（Queen size）。
Are you lying on your bed all day?
你整天躺在床上吗？
Well, I had no choice.
好吧，我没得选。
You're just reclining, or sitting on it, or?
你是只是躺着，还是坐着，还是？
I was just lying. Now, I had two pillows, and they were very wet, but that was all right. I was used to that.
我只是躺着。现在，我有两个枕头，它们非常湿，但没关系。我习惯了。
Up to where on your body, the water?
水在你身体的哪个位置？
Well, there was times when it was about mid-thigh. There was one time the first day, my chest of drawers turned so that the back was up, and I stepped on it in hopes of climbing on the bed. And it just flipped me right into the water, and I went under the water for a second. And I just held my breath a little bit and floated right on up.
嗯，有些时候在大腿中部。有一次第一天，我的抽屉柜翻了，后背朝上，我踩在上面希望爬到床上。它直接把我翻进了水里，我在水下待了一秒钟。我只是屏住呼吸，直接浮了上来。
My refrigerator in the kitchen went belly-up. I couldn't open the door. My refrigerator had that little door outside that has the water and the juice and the milk on the door. So I opened that, and I was able to get some orange juice out. And then I took off my meat cleaver, and I kind of broke one side of that little thing. I got some raisins, some cheese, and each morning I have a few bites because I didn't know how long I'd be there. And I said, I have to have a few bites every day. And then, late in the day when I got hungry, well, I just kind of ignored it.
厨房里的冰箱翻了个身。我打不开门。我的冰箱外面有个小门，上面放着水、果汁和牛奶。所以我打开了那个，我能拿出一些橙汁。然后我拿过我的切肉刀，我弄坏了那个小东西的一侧。我得到了一些葡萄干、一些奶酪，每天早上我都吃几口，因为我不知道我会待在那多久。我说，我每天必须吃几口。然后，天晚了当我饿的时候，好吧，我就忽略它。
And to my great disappointment, when I came here and I had my physical, I had not lost one ounce. I was really disappointed there, because I was counting on, at least I want to get something out of this. I want to lose a few pounds, but I didn't.
令我非常失望的是，当我来到这里进行体检时，我没瘦一盎司。我对此感到非常失望，因为我指望，至少我得从中得到点什么。我想减掉几磅，但我没减。
What did you do about water?
你用水怎么办？
Well, I had a full gallon. I decided 12 ounces was enough for the day. I'd have 12 ounces of water, and that kept my kidneys healthy enough.
嗯，我有一满加仑。我决定一天12盎司就够了。我会喝12盎司水，这让我的肾脏保持足够健康。
It sounds like you had survival experience. How would you know?
听起来你有生存经验。你怎么知道？
Well, the reason-- I was in nursing for 42 years, and I kind of knew how some things would be. People say, weren't you frightened that this was happening to you? Not really. It's just the will to say I will not succumb to this. But I wasn't even thinking like that. I was just thinking of all practical things, because I knew eventually someone would find me.
好吧，原因——我做了42年护理，我有点知道事情会怎么样。人们说，你没被发生在你身上的事吓坏吗？其实没。只是说我不向这屈服的意志。但我甚至没那样想。我只是在想所有实际的事情，因为我知道最终有人会找到我。
Sounds like you were awfully calm. What else would you do to keep your spirits up?
听起来你非常冷静。你还做了什么来保持心情舒畅？
When I was just lying there, I just kind of said, well, Louann, you know, you have this furniture, some of it about 40 years, and time to get some more anyway. I watch garden and-- what is that HGTV thing? And I watch that a lot. I enjoy that. When I'm bored with something else on TV and there's stupid stuff, I go to that.
当我只是躺在那儿时，我只是说，好吧，卢安，你知道，你有这些家具，其中一些约40年了，无论如何是时候再买一些了。我看了花园和——那个HGTV的东西是什么？我经常看那个。我很享受。当我厌倦了电视上的其他东西，有愚蠢的东西时，我就看那个。
So they're talking about color all the time, beautiful colors. Oranges-- well, I wouldn't want red or anything like that, but maybe a pale orange or a pale yellow. And then I thought, well, now I have a chance, and I never really liked the Formica they had on my countertops, so I thought, now I'll get marble. And I did not like the floor covering they had on it, now I'll get ceramic tile. The carpet, of course, has got to be thrown out. But I said, now I'll have hardwood floors, because that's what I want anyway. Saying, oh, that looks pretty good.
所以他们一直在谈论色彩，美丽的色彩。橙色——好吧，我不想要红色之类的，但也许是浅橙色或浅黄色。然后我想，好吧，现在我有机会了，而且我从来没真正喜欢过我台面上的福米卡（Formica），所以我想，现在我要买大理石。而且我不喜欢它上面的地板覆盖物，现在我要买陶瓷地砖。地毯，当然，得扔掉。但我说，现在我要铺硬木地板，因为无论如何那是我想要的。说着，噢，看起来相当不错。
So you're on your mattress every day, just lying there, and you're thinking about redecorating your house?
所以你每天在床垫上，只是躺着，你在想重新装修你的房子？
Well, yeah, I did. That's the way I was motivating myself. If I was going to say, oh poor me, I might die here of this or that, or why don't somebody come and get me? I figured they would eventually make rounds, and they would find me.
好吧，是的，我做了。那就是我激励自己的方式。如果我要说，噢可怜的我，我可能会死在这里或其他什么，或者为什么没有人来接我？我想他们最终会巡视的，他们会找到我的。
During those eight days, what did you miss the most?
那八天里，你最想念什么？
I have so many TVs in my house, because I love television. I have six. I had one in each bedroom. In the great room was like two in there, because I had a very large one, 53, for sports. I'm an avid sports fan, so I love all the tennis, all the golf, and all the basketball. So I enjoy that on my large screen. But I never missed it one time, and I could not understand why I didn't miss it. I really did not miss it.
我的房子里有好多电视，因为我热爱电视。我有六台。每个卧室有一台。大房间里有两台，因为我有一个非常大的，53英寸，为了体育节目。我是一个狂热的体育迷，所以我喜欢所有的网球、高尔夫和篮球。所以我喜欢在大屏幕上享受那个。但我一次也没想念它，我无法理解为什么没想念它。我真的没想念它。
And what were you wearing during all this time?
这段时间你穿什么？
A bra. That's all, because everything else got so wet. I mean, I didn't have anything anyway. I had that old muumuu that I wore outside. I had that on the first day of the storm, and that was wet. After that, through these eight days, I just had on a bra, nothing more.
胸罩。就那样，因为其他一切都太湿了。我的意思，我无论如何什么都没有。我穿了那件我在外面穿的旧muumuu（夏威夷连身裙）。风暴第一天我穿了那个，那是湿的。在那之后，这八天里，我只穿了一个胸罩，没有别的。
Did you learn anything about yourself that you didn't know before?
你对自己了解到了以前不知道的事情吗？
Well, always my upcoming, I was terribly, terribly, terribly poor when I was growing up. And I thought that there was a white world and a black world. I thought white people had things that black people didn't have because of the two worlds, and blacks were not permitted those things. Well, when I grew up, and I left Louisiana when I was 17 years old and ended up in Michigan, I discovered, oh, money was the problem.
嗯，总是我的成长过程，我长大时非常、非常、非常贫穷。我以为有一个白人的世界和一个黑人的世界。我以为白人有黑人没有的东西，因为这两个世界，黑人不允许有这些东西。好吧，当我长大，17岁离开路易斯安那州，最终在密歇根州时，我发现，噢，钱才是问题。
So when I discovered that, then I said-- I don't know, I can say I set out to prove that I could be equal. And so I educated myself. I set out to improve myself. I was the kind of person, I have so many clothes. No one woman ever needed as many clothes as I've had in my life. I had pajamas that I had never worn: silk, beautiful pajamas. I have two full-length mink coats, and I have a beautiful Persian.
所以当我发现这一点后，我就说——我不知道，我可以说是为了证明我可以平等。所以我教育了自己。我决心改善自己。我就是那样的人，我有好多衣服。没有一个女人一生中需要像我那样多的衣服。我有从未穿过的睡衣：丝绸的，漂亮的睡衣。我有两件全长的水貂皮大衣，还有一件漂亮的波斯皮草。
It was just ironic that, when I arrived here, I came here in an old muumuu which I didn't notice that was on the wrong side. I had no underclothes on, and I had no shoes. I've had 100 pairs of shoes in my lifetime. So I never want to own all that stuff again.
这真是讽刺，当我来到这里时，我穿了一件旧muumuu，我甚至没注意到它是反着穿的。我没穿内衣，也没穿鞋。我一生中有100双鞋。所以我再也不想拥有所有那些东西了。
So you realized you just didn't need all of that?
所以你意识到你只是不需要所有那些东西？
Right, I didn't need all of that.
对，我不需要所有那些东西。
After her rescue, Louann Mims was put on a plane to Chicago wearing only the muumuu she was rescued in and a pair of socks that a relief worker gave her. She's currently at a facility run by the state of Illinois, hoping to get a new apartment somewhere near her daughter. The daughter plans to write a thank you letter to the mattress company, Stearns & Foster, at some point. She talked with Alex Kotlowitz, author of Never a City So Real, There Are No Children Here, and other books.
获救后，卢安·米姆斯被送上一架飞往芝加哥的飞机，身上只穿着她获救时的muumuu和救援人员给她的一双袜子。她目前在伊利诺伊州运营的一个设施里，希望在她女儿附近找一套新公寓。她女儿计划在某个时候给床垫公司Stearns & Foster写一封感谢信。她与亚历克斯·科特洛维茨谈过，他是《Never a City So Real》、《There Are No Children Here》和其他书籍的作者。
Well, our program was produced today by Sarah Koenig, Julie Snyder, and myself, with Alex Blumberg, Diane Cook, Jane Feltes, Amy O'Leary, and Lisa Pollak. Julie's also our senior producer. Elizabeth Meister runs our website. Production help from Todd Bachmann and Chris Ladd.
好吧，我们的节目今天由莎拉·凯尼格（Sarah Koenig）、朱莉·斯奈德（Julie Snyder）和我本人制作，亚历克斯·布伦伯格（Alex Blumberg）、黛安·库克（Diane Cook）、简·费尔特斯、艾米·奥利里（Amy O'Leary）和丽莎·波拉克参与。朱莉也是我们的高级制片人。伊丽莎白·迈斯特（Elizabeth Meister）负责我们的网站。托德·巴赫曼（Todd Bachmann）和克里斯·拉德（Chris Ladd）提供制作帮助。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
（致谢）
Our website, www.thisamericanlife.org, where you can listen to any of our programs for absolutely free, or buy CDs of them. Or you know you can download today's program, or our archives, at audible.com/thisamericanlife. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
我们的网站，www.thisamericanlife.org，在那里您可以完全免费收听我们的任何节目，或购买CD。或者您知道您可以在audible.com/thisamericanlife下载今天的节目，或我们的档案。《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
（资助者名单）
WBEZ management oversight for our program by Mr. Torey Malatia, who most weeks has this reaction when he hears our show:
我们的节目由WBEZ管理监督，由托里·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）先生负责，他大部分周听到我们的节目时都有这种反应：
Phew. Oh. Oh. Oh God, that will make you puke.
呼。噢。噢。噢，上帝，那会让你呕吐。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of this American life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回更多美国生活的故事。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。